SARAH WELDON: Hello, and welcome
to Engage and Translate--
Text and Audio Chat
in Over 100 Languages.
I'm Sarah Weldon, Product
Manager for Google Cloud
Translation Services,
which include
APIs for pre-trained
and customizable machine
translation models, and a
new beta API for supporting
streaming audio translation.
More on that later.
I'll be joined
later in this talk
with Dale Markowitz, Applied
AI engineer at Google Cloud.
And she'll bring
some of the features
that we are discussing to
life in a couple of demos.
Today's companies, their
employees, and their customers
are truly global.
And every day, they're
also more digital.
Keeping pace with the
exchange of information
in multiple languages at
scale is a growing challenge,
especially so when more
work is moving to virtual.
So companies are turning
to machine learning
to augment their workloads and
to make content more accessible
faster than would be
possible without automation.
Luckily, advances in
machine translation
continue to drive up quality.
And new features on our
products give customers
more control over how their
content is translated.
More on that later.
Let's take a quick look
at where we started.
Pre-2016, the world is
relying on statistical machine
translation.
As an example for this,
we take a set paragraph
from a Japanese language and
we translated it into English
for readability.
So in this case, this
translates as, Kilimanjaro
is 19,710 feet of the
mountain covered with snow
and it said to be a
highest mountain in Africa.
It's a little awkward
in how it's written,
as well as there's
some words missing
if you are a fluent reader.
But if we fast forward to
today, we've done a lot of work
to improve machine translation
using machine learning.
And so Google introduced a
neural machine translation
after 2016 and into 2017.
And under that new model,
this same translation
would come through
as, Kilimanjaro
is a mountain of 19,710
feet covered with snow
and is said to be the
highest mountain in Africa.
It's a much more
fluent translation.
It doesn't feel awkward.
And it's a good number of words.
But we keep improving,
even beyond this.
In summary, the last major
jump in quality we saw
was in 2016 to 2017.
But we've continuously improved
over the years as well.
And in the most recent year,
which you see with this graph
in green, we saw an increased
jump over multiple languages
through a number of different
technology investments
driven by our research
teams, and an average
of 5-point blue score jump
over 100-plus languages.
And this improvement is
comparable to the gain
observed years ago
when translating
from statistical to neural
machine translation, as I
spoke about a few minutes ago.
So our products include
Translation API Basic,
Translation API Advanced,
and AutoML translation,
and then the new one
that I was talking
about a little bit later.
For Translation API Basic,
the implementations on it
are really intended
for simple use cases.
It's intended for
user-generated content
where you're not
trying to control
a lot of the specific
translations.
So we wanted to make
it very simple to use.
And so Translation API Basic
does do important things still
with language detection.
And it also continues to use the
advancements of the new machine
learning models as we release
them and develop new languages.
But you can use
Translation API Basic
for chat scenarios and
user-generated content,
because it's easy
to integrate with
and you're not trying to change
the translations after the fact
for a number of these cases.
But in this
user-generated content,
it still is really
easy to use and will
enable you to easily
integrate with many languages
at a very simple platform.
As an example
case, I'll tell you
a little bit about a
gaming scenario, where
we had one of our customers,
in this case, ELEX,
which publishes games
in mobile gaming chat.
And their gamers
are international.
And so when the gamers are
wanting to talk to each other
and collaborate in order
to achieve certain goals,
or to just chat
online, they sometimes
need to be able to cross
between the multiple languages.
And so by integrating with
the Translation API Basic,
ELEX is able to improve
the engagement experience
for their end users and be able
to improve the overall gaming
experience just by
connecting in with our APIs.
But this isn't just specific
to gaming or to tech.
It's actually really useful for
government scenarios as well.
So let's talk about
another customer scenario,
this time, public sector.
Within the US, many
languages are spoken,
and governments are
required to make
information accessible
to their constituents.
Let's look at how
machine translation
can help with this scenario.
So I'll turn it over to Dale.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Thanks, Sarah.
I'm Dale.
I'm an applied AI
engineer here at Google.
And I'm talking to you
from Austin, Texas.
Texas is a really
interesting state
because it's actually the
second most multilingual state
in the US, after California.
And something like
one in three people
don't actually speak English
as their first language
in their homes.
So it's really
important, especially in
times like these,
that the city is
able to communicate
with constituents
in their own languages.
So I recently had heard
about this project.
It was actually done
by the state of Hawaii,
where they used the Google
Translate API to automatically
translate a bunch of
legislative documents
so that all of
their constituents
could understand the documents.
So I kind of wondered, could I
do the same thing for Austin?
So I decided I would go
to the Austin website,
and I found a bunch of different
questions that people ask.
Where do I take out
my garbage or how do I
report a leaking fire hydrant?
And I decided to
build a chat bot that
understands questions and
then gives the city's answers.
But I used the
Translation API to be
able to detect what language
people are asking in,
and then respond in
their own language.
So let's take a look.
This is a chat app that I
built to answer questions
about the city of Austin.
It recognizes lots of languages.
So for example, if
I ask how to check
if I'm registered
to vote in Spanish,
it will detect my language
and use the Translation API
to respond in the same language.
The Translation API supports
over 100 different languages
and lots of different
character sets,
so you can write your
app code once and have
it work all over the world.
So the demo that
I just showed you,
it was working with a chat bot
that had some preset answers.
But actually, the architecture
works exactly the same
for any sort of chat--
like for example, if
I was building a chat
app to chat with
Sarah and we wanted
to use two different languages.
So let me walk you
through how it works.
So the first thing
you might have noticed
is that you didn't actually have
to specify what language you
wanted to use chat in.
That's because the
Translation API,
if you give it enough
text, can actually
tell what the language is.
So the text gets sent from
the chat client to a server.
The Translation API
detects the language.
And then it translates
the sentence to English
because my chat bot only
understands English.
Then once the chat
bot replies, we
use the Translation API
again to translate back
to the sender's language
and send the response back
to the chat.
And that's how you can build
a translation chat app.
Now, this worked really well
for the majority of the cases
that I tested.
But there were some where
it didn't do that well,
in terms of translation quality.
And those are the cases where
there was some really specific
Austin terminology, like
the name of our metro system
or some really specific
words for things in Austin.
So I'm going to hand
it back to Sarah,
and she'll tell you how
you can improve quality
for domain-specific cases.
SARAH WELDON: Thanks, Dale.
That was great.
Now let's talk
about what we can do
to modify content
to better represent
different possible
translations within a language,
depending on the industry
context or location.
So in this scenario, I'm
thinking of public sector
again.
And it's a pretty
common thing to want
to be able to provide
comments to a public agency--
in this case, let's say
the attorney general.
Now if you were
talking to users that
are in Spanish, that
are speaking Spanish,
there is a pretty
common translation
for attorney general,
which is fiscal general.
So in this case, our
machine translation
would automatically select this
for the translated response.
But there are other countries,
say in Latin America,
that might have a different
version of what they call
their attorney general's
office-- in this case,
Ministerio Publico Fiscal.
But even in California,
they actually
have a pre-described glossary.
And if you look at
that, they refer
to their attorney
general's office in Spanish
as Procurador General.
So what if you could
customize your translations
to your domain?
With Translation API Advanced,
you can actually do this.
And if you have a
terminology base, which
a lot of public organizations
do, and companies do,
as well, then you can use
this as your starting point
with an easy integration with
Translation API Advanced.
Because you have your
English terms and your terms
in other target
languages, if you just
create this into a CSV file
and import it into your Google
Cloud project, then
you can use this
with future cases for
machine translation
just by referencing your
glossary in your Translation
API call, and then when
you get the response back,
it'll actually preserve
your preferred term
over what the machine
translation might
have otherwise predicted.
And Translation
API Advanced also
has other features that
can help with both scaling
your implementation, as well
as more advanced customization
capabilities with our custom
machine translation models.
All of that can be done
through one API integrated
with your GCP project.
But let's say you have even
more than just terminology
and you want to go further.
You're company or
organization that
has a lot of past
human translations.
And you want to be able to use
those translations to improve
the machine translation
prediction for what
a translation would likely be
for your content, your context,
or your industry.
So in that case,
it's really important
to understand
conceptually that Google
has both pre-trained models,
which is what you typically
use with machine Translation
API Advanced or Translation API
Basic.
And these are pre-trained
models that we've created
using a lot of training data.
But if you have your
own training data,
you can actually use
those as a starting point,
and then build and
improve on them
with a custom training
on AutoML Translation.
So by taking your past
human translations,
bringing that to our platform,
and running trainings on it,
then you're improving the
statistical and mathematical
likelihood that our model
is going to provide back
to you a translation that's
tuned to your context
and to your industry.
So it does this through
transfer learning.
And it has an entire
platform where
you can go and learn and
manage more of these models
to integrate it with more
advancements in your platform.
But now, let's go back
to our chat scenario.
Our chat app uses the right
language, but it doesn't speak.
It's actually just
using text translation.
So since users both
write and talk,
there are scenarios where
we might want to have audio,
as well as text translation
supported for our use cases.
So can we translate
speech in real time?
Organizations are seeing value
in delivering their products
and content globally.
And it's not just in text.
It's in video.
It's in audio.
It's in calls.
And so for these
scenarios, you want
to be able to have an easier
way to implement translations
for those use cases.
And it's applicable in
media entertainment.
It's applicable in technology.
And it's applicable
for service providers
that might be trying to
support customer support cases.
But what's so complicated
about translating nontext data
with audio and video?
We have our speech
APIs and our video APIs
that allow for interacting
with those types of content.
And we have translations,
so we can just
integrate between
all three of them
in order to be able
to get an outcome.
But it's kind of hard to do.
And it comes with
other challenges
that are nearly
impossible to solve
on the developer-client side.
So we're looking at how to
solve that on the cloud side.
For one thing, latency
can be a lot higher
if you're integrating across
multiple APIs, especially
if one is set up for
streaming and the other one
is setup for more
synchronous cases, where
it's waiting for the
content to finish
before it starts to figuring
out what a translation would be.
Additionally, you have
to do multiple API calls.
So that can be a
complexity for developers
to work with, especially if
they're trying to figure out
how to improve
accuracy, et cetera,
across these two different APIs.
And then you're also dealing
with a streaming client,
which creates some
complexities with integrations
and usability.
And it's a challenge in itself.
So Media Translation API
simplifies this process.
It supports directly audio
files or microphone input,
say through a mobile phone
or through your browser.
And it also accepts
that content directly,
so you're not having to run
through a speech model first
and then a translation
model in order
to get a translation back.
You can go directly
to Media Translation
API with your audio,
and you'll get back
a text translation
in the language which
you've set as your target
language for translation
outcome.
In addition to abstracting away
the frictions of multiple API
calls, we have some
other features that
overall improve the experience.
So automatic
punctuation detection,
as well as using
enhanced models for video
or telephoning use
cases allows you
to be able to make the most to
get the best quality optimized
for your audio
translation outputs.
And then we also have
language support,
because it's a
translation model.
So we support French, German,
Italian, Hindi, Portuguese,
Russian, Spanish,
English, and others,
for you to be able to
translate multiple languages
for your user base.
So with that, I'll
take it back to Dale
so we can see the Media
Translation API in action.
DALE MARKOWITZ:
Thank you, Sarah.
So as a developer, I
can confirm that it
is tricky to do anything
in real time, especially
real-time translation.
But the Media Translation
API makes this a lot easier,
which is great, because there
are so many times I want
to do real-time translation.
Like imagine if I'm
doing a live stream
and I want users all around
the world to understand it.
Or maybe I'm giving
a talk in person
and I want different
audience members
with different languages
to get what I'm saying.
So I'm going to
show you something
that I built with the
Media Translation API
and the Raspberry Pi
and the Mini Projector.
And let's take a look.
Hi, my name is Dale.
I'm using the Media Translation
API and a Raspberry Pi
to translate what I'm
saying in real time.
So that is what I'm bringing
to my talk next time
I give a talk somewhere that
speaks a different language.
And with that, I'll
give it back to Sarah.
SARAH WELDON: Thanks, Dale.
I wanted to close with
some thoughts from one
of our translation customers
for Media Translation API.
When they integrated with
our Media Translation API,
they were able to see
games in low latency,
as well as the overall
quality of performance.
And so they're able to
provide real-time streaming
translation for video chat.
OnePlus is a phone provider.
And they've created
a beta application
that allows for their customers
to be able to opt in and be
able to see the
translations from the person
that they're speaking
in a different language
while they're still engaged
with them in video chat.
And so with this, we're
able to demonstrate
how text translation
and audio translation
can work seamlessly together
to create a better end
user experience.
To close, I wanted to point
you to our documentation
on our Cloud website, where
you can get more information
on AutoML translation,
Translation API
Advanced, and our new
Media Translation API.
Please check them out.
Thanks for joining us.